are you still with offline sweet yeah
i'm still offline tv right now yeah
so what is that you guys stream together
and it's like a content collective
it's more like content like we do
youtube videos like it's a singular
youtube video and then everyone just
like does their kind of own thing
yeah right right they're all just kind
of planning how to burn
a
um federal organizations it's a joke
since we already know
you know who michael is he's kidding
offline is not affiliated with any kind
of arsonistic
one guy reeves fbi assigned agent is
like [ __ ] raves
he was good look at him burning [ __ ]
down
[Laughter]
damn that's sick though so you live in
the house right with all them
how many people are in there there's
like i don't know like seven or eight or
something
yeah it's nice like it's it's quite it's
good like everyone hangs out where
everyone's very chill everyone's like
streaming like all day long so you can
play video games with them whenever it's
just quite nice i feel like hot tub oh
yeah hot tub yeah yeah have you guys on
a hot tub stream yet dude we did a hot
tub stream
did you really yeah we did for a meme it
was like it was sweet
very fun it was for a pokey's birthday
we we did a hot dog stream
and it was it was nice oh there it is
right there we just uh
yeah we just we just realized that or we
found out like a few days ago they made
the whole sub category for it
which is wild yeah so it's hot tubs
pools and beaches
is the category beaches man cause like
yeah i've
i remember i went on like just chatting
just arbitrarily at like 2 p.m and i was
like i took a screen cap with the first
three rows and it was all just like hot
tubs beaches and pools i was like dying
laughing i was like
this makes me feel like such a joke that
i clock in at 4 pm and i'm like i'm
gonna tell
jokes it's like yeah we don't care yeah
yeah you really don't care
you are you are literally the last thing
we give a [ __ ] about
in this category yeah we tell to tell
them about the hawaii
oh yeah yeah yeah so so i went to maui
and then i did the big island oh nice
yeah for a couple weeks
oh that's sweet yeah so i was staying in
my hotel on the big island
and i'm walking back from our room to go
hang out at a beach and look at like a
little beach area
and i see a [ __ ] i see a ring light
just like it's like in the middle of all
this greenery there's a ring light i'm
like what the [ __ ] is going on here
and i'm expecting a teenager to just be
in front of it you know just rip that
and and i get a few more steps as a
gopro
and it's definitely a like a
beach streamer yeah trying to get her
settings right and i'm
laughing because i can tell she's like
fussing with the twitch app on her phone
through the gopro app and i wanted to be
like hey i already tried it it doesn't
work
out here yeah i'm a streamer as well
[Laughter]
you may know me michael reeves he just
pulls in
you see maybe on the category that's
what i was thinking is that like you
know like
you know emerging creators these days
it's like you know you're trying to
grind for like the category that you
want to go for right people like you
know i want to be a commentary person
whatever so you gotta
but like you know if you're just
starting out maybe you can't afford a
hot tub in a or a pool
so then you just go to public pools yeah
stream from there
yeah there's like children doing
swimming lessons in the background dog
and you're like
sorry i didn't hear dude thank you for
the sub
some people do it in their bathtubs yeah
and like frame it as if it were a hot
tub
in a way it's just like this is just a
horny thing right
yeah there's no like creative integrity
i'm not gonna take it
damn you can't be creative in the hot
tub space cody
or a gatekeeper i meant like there's no
like real merit to like the it doesn't
like
lift the content besides like it just
makes it hornier right
um isn't that what everyone's talking
about what if you're a hot tub streamer
but you're a musician
people play violin in the hot tub i
would watch that yeah i would watch that
all right so what what if someone's
doing like crazy
algebra with an abacus in a hot tub
i would watch that too but that's my
question for you is there anyone doing
that that's the main gripe with hot tub
servers like that's like the main like
when people talk about it yeah that's
yeah that's that is like the main group
okay yeah
that's what i'm getting at it's pretty
ridiculous that twitch made it its own
thing when they're pretty like and
they're supposed to be anti that stuff
anyways right
it's like it's skirts i think i've seen
stuff about like
um they skirt exactly like the line
of where the twitch terms of service go
which you definitely have to give them
credit for that
because you're not allowed to be in like
um like have your shirt off or have like
like swimsuit bikini on normally but
only in the context where it makes sense
so in the hot tub
that does make sense right you can't
just have it off and you're like sitting
in a gamer chair
that does that would get you like
probably bound on twitch but they skirt
the fine line
what if you just came in from the pool i
don't know
oops i went live
[Laughter]
oh i just went live i was just tanning
out back oops i fell on my live button
oh and it's any and it's like this
oops i fell on my live button
no no it was just showing my cleavage to
the wall yeah
live button by accident no you you do
have to give credit that
the the in the ingenious
approach like oh what if what if i'm in
a hot tub then i would have to wear it
you do have to give credit there oh i'll
give credit to people trying to skirt
twitch's rules it's just funny when
twitch is then like
well they got us we got to make it a
category i gotta get the category
yeah that that is an interesting
decision that's the part i mean bro come
on
you know they got a room full of mods
and they were just like
[Laughter]
it's pretty cool is it that bad yeah
is it that bad i think it was making
people mad that they were in just
chatting category
yeah because that was just filling up
the just chatting category yeah yeah so
in that respect like i think
for them it's like what's gonna happen
you know
and what are they going to do hire a
team of qa people to be like
it's just you know manual bands on hot
tubs
like you know i get creating a
space for it yeah right people are like
i just want to see chatting
get all these horny nonsenses out of the
chatting category see a guy telling
jokes i want to see a guy
chat to me
[Laughter]
yeah bro it's just hilarious because
you just yeah i love the the category
too like
pool what is it it's like pools spas
pools peaches and hot peaches
beaches and a hot tub like that they put
the two in let me think
kind of those things don't really relate
they definitely
have water but they're not they have
nothing to do with each other
besides being in a bikini would make
sense there
it would make sense i mean there i have
seen like a couple streams with uh
like you know some woman in a bikini at
like a literal like kid's pool
really yeah like there was one yeah like
there was one where like
me and siva were [ __ ] crying like
because it was so glaring because when i
took that screen cap he's like bruh bruh
and he like clipped something from her
stream and she's like
like almost like doing yoga or something
like and
very obviously ten-year-olds just in the
background just like with toys so it was
like her
like apartment pool or something like
that it was like a public pool yeah but
it was just sort of
the juxtaposition was definitely there
it's massive yeah and you're kind of
like um
[Music]
no they weren't met no i'm sorry
um he tends to get crazy sometimes when
talking about
chesticles but yeah no it was like they
were straight up
looks like kids like in the background
so i don't know it's kind of a
there's no like philosophy here like
it's an interesting in-between to see
those two things
yeah yeah i know which matters for me
yeah there's nothing to debate i was
about to just go on a deep like
is this gonna promote half-naked women
in child spaces
okay uh yeah i'm just kidding cuddy the
situation
yeah you know that hot tub streamer that
died
[Music]
her live streaming backpack fell in a
public jacuzzi and it killed her
toddler
she was carrying killed a pool full of
kids
hit an electric boat